we do have team coverage tonight joe
moller is north of the crash with
reaction from the cycling community
but first kristen drummond joins us live
where the investigation
just wrapped up kristin brian yes
nhp was out here for roughly five hours
investigating they wrapped up about
five or 45 minutes ago as you can see
u.s 95 south and north are back open to
traffic
and hp says four men and one woman
died in this crash that they are calling
horrific
it happened at around 9 30 this morning
troopers say cyclists were riding south
on u.s 95
and they were with a supporting gear car
also known as a sag vehicle
at some point a white box truck driving
the same direction
went into their lane the reason why
remains unknown right now but
impairment is not suspected nhp says the
cyclists on the ride were familiar with
the route
and made this trip before
until today's tragedy they have never
had any problems they didn't have a
safety vehicle with them
what i understand though is the safety
vehicle
ended up in a position where their
bicycle was both in front of it
at the time of this crash
the crash at one point shut down the
northbound lanes of u.s 95 for roughly
an
hour nhp says the driver of the sag car
was hospitalized
one person was also airlifted troopers
add the box truck driver is not hurt
and continues to cooperate with law
enforcement
i'm told the group started at the m
resort casino this morning it was part
of a birthday group ride they were
supposed to go 130 miles coming down
here on us 95 south to searchlight
cutting over the pass to nipton
and then over to i-15 and back to the m
resort
reporting live on u.s 95 south krista
drummond 8 news now